what's up youtubes welcome back to my
channel Richard on data my name is
Richard and this is the channel where we
talk about data so a couple weeks ago I
did a video called why you shouldn't
become a data scientist and I really
tried to stress in that video that if
you're trying to get into the data
science world if you don't know what
you're getting yourself into your
expectations aren't aligned with reality
you're probably setting yourself up for
failure but if you missed that video the
link will be in the description but I
did try to stress in that video that I
really enjoy the data science world I've
enjoyed every single data science job
that I've personally worked in I found
every single one of them a little bit
different but they've all been enriching
in their own individual way so I want to
do like a part two to that video where I
detail what the real perks and benefits
of being a data scientist really are
because let's face it the field is
white-hot right now and there's no way
that the field would be this booming if
people in it didn't genuinely really
enjoy the work so as usual these are
gonna be based on my own personal
experience they're also augmented by
anecdotes from people that I keep in my
network as well as research that I've
done naturally every single job is
different but I really think the chance
of these things being true is gonna be
much higher in data science than it
typically is gonna be in other fields so
before we get into things smash that
like button hit the subscribe button and
also hit the notification bell so you
never miss an update so perk number one
of being a data scientist and you all
probably guess this one it's money
so this one is pretty straightforward
and honestly I have talked about it on
this channel before but the money really
is outstanding there's tons of metrics
out there on this but here's a couple
the ones that I personally find the most
impressive in 2018 birch works did a
study on this they found the median
starting salary for a data scientist is
$95,000 now granted that is a starting
salary that's not factoring in years of
experience you work your way up you get
read
as you move up none of that that is a
starting salary
Glassdoor at the time I'm recording this
video which is December of 2019 they're
reporting the average base pay of a data
scientist to be one hundred twenty
thousand four hundred and ninety five
dollars so obviously there are a lot of
factors that go into this namely what
sector are you in are you in the private
sector are you in the public sector or
are you in a start-up so startups
generally pay the highest followed by
any other private sector job followed by
the public sector if you're in the
United States the two regions of the
country which are gonna pay the highest
are the East Coast particularly the New
York City Boston area and then also the
Bay Area
they are generally gonna pay higher than
the middle of the country is and then
naturally years of experience matter as
you work your way up you're gonna get
raises but you also have tons of
opportunities as well to leave your job
go somewhere else and make even more
money
the second perk is that's a very
creative field and now this one is a
little bit subjective but I think for
the vast majority of people they get
really bored if they're doing the exact
same thing day in and day out I know
it's definitely the case for me and if
I'm not learning and constantly pushing
the boundaries for myself I'm going to
get bored and I'm gonna get restless
really quickly the thing is data science
is by its very nature a very creative
field because you generally work on very
open-ended problems of which there's not
just one way to skin the cat there's
always different ways that you can
attack a problem so you have to
critically examine what is the best
solution for your given problem now that
should in and of itself keep you doing
different things a lot of the time
because honestly the field is so broad
there's so many different techniques out
there and there's so many different
things out there to explore you should
inside the capacity of your job get the
opportunity to explore a lot of
different things
and if your job unfortunately doesn't
provide those opportunities it's really
easy to leave your job and go somewhere
else that is going to allow you to
explore and learn the things that you
want to which brings me to perk number
three which is career opportunities so
there's definitely a lot of jobs out
there which could seem like dead ends
you can stay in them for several years
you work your way up but it's really
difficult to see where to go next
and people end up stuck in there and
having to make lateral career moves that
is definitely not the case with data
science in fact there's tons of
flexibility to move up to exactly where
you want to go as an individual it's
common for people to work their way up
to positions like a senior or principal
data scientist and that's typically
still kind of a technical role and
people can stay in a technical role if
they want to a lot of people end up
transitioning out of doing the technical
stuff from day to day and I think the
reason for that is because communication
in data science is such a big part of
the job you're flexing your soft skill
muscles so much that transitioning to
things like managerial directorial or
even leading small teams those types of
positions are not that much of a far cry
away naturally say if you're in the
Midwest and you want to transition to
things like big tech or the Fang that is
Facebook Apple Amazon Netflix Google
those kinds of positions are always
options for you as well if you're
actually interested in them Puka number
four you get to keep up with industry
trends and now this one is a little
interesting I actually put it in my
video why you shouldn't be a data
scientist as a negative and the reason I
did that is because I get it it's
overwhelming at times there's tons of
stuff out there that you constantly have
to keep learning and the learning
doesn't stop after college you have to
continuously keep going it doesn't stop
that can really suck sometimes I get it
however the flipside of this is that
you're very unlikely
get completely steamrolled by new
technology because let's face it change
in the industry generally happens pretty
slowly so let's say ten years from now
the big thing everybody's using is Julia
maybe everybody's working in Hadoop
environments you get the opportunity to
see this happening very slowly pay
attention to what's going on out there
and then adapt yourself so what this
will lead to is really good job security
because let's face it the notion of
having a job permanently is kind of a
myth in this day and age having security
in any one job is probably not
necessarily gonna be something that you
can count on but if you have skills
which are highly valuable in the
marketplace
you are never ever going to have trouble
getting hired number five and this one
is huge is there's very low risk of your
job getting automated in the future now
there's a lot of talk out there right
now about automation and what that's
going to look like in the 2020s decade
and honestly this one is up for a little
bit of debate even in the data science
world because even today we're seeing
things like simpler tasks simpler
analytics getting automated and even
things like building models there are
tools out there which make that process
significantly quicker and easier at the
end of the day though data science has
way too much of a soft skills component
intertwined with it though
so there's absolutely no way that we're
going to be able to automate a way
knowing the right question to ask from a
business perspective having all the
domain knowledge that's necessary to ask
the right question
perform all the necessary data science
steps in a pipeline interpret results
and visualizations in a way that
stakeholders can readily comprehend I
just don't see any of that happening any
time soon now something that I do think
is true is that data science in five to
ten years is going to look drastically
different than what it looks like now so
there's going to be all kinds of
different products and service
that get released over the next period
of time and it's just going to make our
lives easier you're probably going to
see more easy and menial tasks getting
automated and that's just going to open
up more of our time and our attention to
where we can focus on bigger and better
and more exciting things
who knows we're probably going to be the
ones automating away a lot of the things
in the world think about that one for a
minute
so overall the field of data science is
fantastic I found it actually by
accident and I'll make a video on this
in the future but I found it and I've
never looked back
like anything though there are a lot of
trade-offs there are positives and there
are negatives so it's on you to get all
of the relevant information for you and
make the right decision for you so
thanks for watching this video until
next time Richard on data